introducing the seven piece gardening
tool set from work pro with six
purpose-built hand tools a pair of
gardening gloves and a convenient
storage tote this set includes a
transplanter with four inch depth
engravings a trowel for digging a hand
fork for aerating and mixing a weeder
for precise weed removal a cultivator
for loosening and spreading soil and a
pair of pruning shears for trimming
stems and small branches
the hand tools feature comfortably
contoured wooden handles for a
comfortable grip and lanyard loops for
additional storage options
built to last with quality components
these tools are sure to serve any
gardener well for years to come
work pro build a better project